- Do you wanna learn
how to stand out online
as social media gets more crowded?
Are you looking for the best marketing
and money making strategies
for growing your online
business and brand faster
with YouTube and online video?
If we're just meeting,
my name is Sean Cannell,
and I'm a small town
kid, college drop out,
and I started making videos
in my bedroom 10 years ago.
All right, so this is I guess
the first Sean Thinks vlog.
Now this is definitely as real as it gets
so I'm not gonna try to be
energetic or entertaining.
Fast forward to today and I've
built a multi million dollar
media company,
and that's what inspired this channel.
A place where the Think Media team and I
reveal the marketing and online
business growth strategies
that we've used to scale
over the past decade.
Our mission is to help
purpose-driven people
learn how to build their
influence with YouTube,
social media, and online video.
On this channel we're
gonna be covering topics
like email marketing, paid advertising,
how to create and sell digital courses,
and advanced strategies
for growing your business
faster with social media.
So make sure to subscribe.
Every week we will post new videos
including our weekly video podcast,
the Think Marketing show
hosted by Heather Torres.
Exclusive sessions from
our annual conference,
Grow With Video Live in Las Vegas,
step-by-step trainings
on marketing campaigns,
funnels, and the best
marketing tools and software,
and so much more.
This channel will help you
shorten your learning curve
and simplify the complex
world of online marketing
so you can build a business you love.
Our core values are
faith, family, and legacy,
and we believe that there has never been
a better time to build a high impact
and high profit business
that not only changes people's lives,
but makes a difference in the world.
So make sure to hit that subscribe button
and turn on notifications
so you never miss an upload.
Talk soon.